all right throw me this shirt here we'll
check back in with mercedes coming up
later in the hour
dear las vegas
what are the odds that a place so empty
would become so full
full of people who make this place home
our friendly oasis in the desert
and how does such a place even exist
by treating every person the same way
like family
part of station casino's new campaign
called from vegas with love featuring
love letters narrated by these stevie
nicks and featuring the music of iconic
group the young bloods the campaign it's
a giant love letter to vegas locals and
newly minted locals along with some
funny inside jokes that only us las
vegas could understand here are those
inside some of those inside jokes we
grew up here that's our house advantage
we don't like paying for parking either
this is the one i love shout out to
everyone that moved here just for a
couple of years and never left
that makes a lot of sense there's more
of these billboards around town and they
sent over some really cool stuff we have
some shirts they sent over today what i
had thrown over to me to see been here
still here and staying here guys uh
locals and proud of it and check out
this cake they sent look at this thing
uh we grew up here and that's our house
advantage i'm gonna show this cake here
can you show it off can you can we see
it can you see it i should say that i
should have took it out of the box
before i showed it on television it's
really cool
yeah great stuff t-shirts for the
weekend let's take a live